no
sono
oggi nuovissima storia rob lowe xvi
ricordando il maria settore che avevo
provato come ad esempio il compleanno di
pace ma questa è una nuova storia che
sarà sembra tranquillo ma in realtà
succederanno delle cose paurose delle
cose su per tra nere ci sono vari finali
quindi in base alle scelte che faremo ci
saranno vari finali dobbiamo stare
sempre attenti ai familiari e sperare
che questa volta riusciamo a capacità
bene perché ricordate le altre finali è
finita molto male devi covo di preti pop
corn iniziamo subito eccoci qua io e
vitale siamo piccolini perché dovremmo
scappare da una sorta di asilo maledetto
lo sei un po strano filtrato il motivo è
entrato ok anch'io sono sul bus xvi qua
siamo scesi dal bus e ora stiamo
entrando nel questa rosa loro ludoteca
ma dove sei insomma perché non ci fanno
entrare insomma possibile dall'altro
lato siamo arrivati da decentrare ciao
ciao mi chiamo lily sta iniziando la
storia mi occupero io di voi per i
prossimi due giorni dai andiamo dentro
ok è che siamo dentro la casa benvenuti
sentitevi liberi di esplorare uomo
sopra cioè non è una casa e l'asilo
questo stile è bellissimo vv chissà se
la baby sitter in realtà noi siamo on
the go altezza nasconde i bambini quali
sono le camere da letto vediamo io cerco
qualche indizio per vedere se lei e con
lei anche io tutto ok non ho trovato
niente dicevamo detto guarda faccio una
storia che casa e un aereo dobbiamo
provarle anche quello
è stato un mi piace ci rimette migliore
10 mila mi piace proveremo anche la
storia in cui cade l'aereo beta ci ha
scritto qualcosa fatto meraviglie sei
iscritto non ho fatto in tempo ecco la
maggior parte delle cose sembrano
migliori quando le metti dentro un
cerchio
lei dice lei sembra che avete fame
venite mangiamo qualcosa al momento di
presentare come un rischio mangiato
la pizza i
ostacolo scivola sembra che i burger
abbiano vinto il voto dice no vado a
ordinarne qualcuno ok per noi burger
vegetariano soldi che ci faceva sorta e
ora che iniziano sono cose strane noi
diamo
risalto
questo è un ottimo nascondiglio man se
n'è andata no è ancora lì chi teme
quindi le cose strane non sono un cuore
hanno suonato alla porta sono già
arrivati a ma forse ordinato io telefono
aspetta allontanati dalla porta vi
ricordate come successo a sua volta mi
metto a guardare tutto da qui dalle
scale sopra beh vediamoci a tavola ok
dovremo andare a dormire adesso aspetta
fammi prima mangiare devi sbrigarti
hanno mangiato
beh io vado noi vogliamo giocare ora si
arrabbia se
saremo svegli comunque lily ha una
faccia le tante cioè questo rispetto
male malefico
[Applauso]
dovesse succedere qualcosa
vado dal centro della luce ha detto sì
perché è mancata la luce o la spenta lei
forse è meglio se paghiamo tutto dice
di chi da qualche parte ho acceso il
camino che era già set ma se c'è stato
premuto una cosa col telecomando sia
accesa non lo so oh my god dico io ho un
obiettivo cos'è quella cosa fuori dalla
finestra sempre tipo un demone un mostro
scappatelle
[Musica]
quella dei villi trasformata a essere il
momento buono di dormire no devi
scappare
mio partito ho letto senti lo vedo lo
vedo non salite qua
mi spaventano io la mina tutto secondo
me questo è un ottimo nascondiglio
guardate qua dove
ottengono senso quanto qualcuno li vedi
non penso che mi dovrebbe
ora però ci troverà sono anch'io
nascosto quanto se ne va via comunque
secondo me è lì lì quella elite sono
anche secondo pezzo è vero basta vedi
non è da nessuna parte pensa quando
qualcuno ha preso qualcuno mobilità
perché doveva sparire così sullo schermo
forse se ne è andato non lo vedo più
spetta rimane fermo lì e non muove
rimuoverlo attiri quasi ti muovi abbiamo
fatto siamo sopravvissuti si
ha detto accesso il governatore quindi
sicuramente lei lilith molto sospetta
[Musica]
lei c'era un mostro che si stava
attaccando dove li cosa diceva un mostro
ma fa finta di niente me smettetela di
fare gli stupidi
andiamo tutti a dormire adesso certo
sarà molto facile dormire ha detto dopo
che chatta caso un debole andata nelle
vostre stanze a dormire ok qual è la mia
staff valle per 30 secondi wow così poco
perché siamo entrati con sabbie mobili
qualcosa mi dice che succederà temono ma
si questo perché dormi con gli occhiali
da sole così almeno non vedo la luce
allora adesso scrivo io non ricevete 0 e
ha detto ha messo addormentandosi
stimolato da una festa c'è qualcosa con
l'elettricità che sta sul nuovo ora
torna il demone torna lily scommetto
scappato
dopotutto siamo mi esalto suoi seni sono
già giù per cui non ha visto no io no
tutto vero maestro perché siete rimasti
qua sì ma non sono riuscita a vedere
cos'era è retto bene tu a salire qua
sopra un letto a castello era e mostro
ma non ho visto anch'io dice la ragazza
suonando la sveglia e forse perché
mattino buongiorno ragazzi
dove
lilli veli per thiene di sotto per fare
colazione si è
conservato la doccia eccola lo sappiamo
che vedute certo io non voglio stare
cugino dove la cucina non lo vedo lei è
protetta da un vetro forse ora vorrei
attaccarci vabbè io mi siedo e schiaccia
schiaccia il cibo ci mangiamo anche
io li adoro
eccoli qua non so perché mi sono
spostata forse perché altrimenti vitale
vero bere bene non ai banchieri ce ne
approfitto della sua distrazione per
andare a cercare qualche prova che sia
lei temi acceso tv insomma non prendere
tempo davanti alla tv dobbiamo cercare
una probabile il demoni sammito il
signore sono che
si no mi sono sappiamo nei time di
giocare i marchigiani ok allora io sono
salito qui sullo scivolo e adesso che
facessimo sono uscita uscire fuori con
una coppia bellissimo in più forse da
parte di mille per il demone prenderci
può rivelarsi volo anzi dai mentre tiro
di spin go si spinga
fatto cadere
e dovremmo preoccuparci del derma invece
di giocare questo parcheggio di brava
bella
linea proviamo a scappare poi dalla
foresta dalla foresta non mi fa scappare
e allora cerchiamo gli indizi sul tempo
né ok ma non c'è niente però guarda
legge osserva siamo tornati dentro ei
sondando roba non vuol dire che
tornerebbe anche lei è debole lo
sappiamo
perché sta chiamando me sarai tu la
responsabile mi farò le responsabili del
gruppo tornare tutti che che si
comportino bene perché
ok di cibo ma non voglio fare la baby
effetto
ti fa fare i dispetti allora ray insomma
non capisci che tra poco arriverà il
demone di nuovo magari vado uova la sala
responsabile finalmente di noi forse
vedere se te la mia testa questo è il
mostro di prima app che sta succedendo
colombi
proprio qua vicino si sta cercando si è
come giocare a nascondino stavano un
uomo non mi dire che sta mettendo a
fuoco casa entrato dentro al camino
il mostro sabato adesso guarda l'aspetto
a cuocere un estintore mi ricordo
davvero io ok siamo l'estintore ok dai
primati come ti aiuta premio fatelo pure
ma come facciamo adesso clicca briga
nessuno eccomi
prima tifosa tutto a fuoco anche il
cammino è il massimo che dobbiamo
spegnere
certo fatta
la prima volta che sopravviviamo che si
allunga infatti dovranno scavare o
aspettare che il i ritorni gara
anemone ora dovremo votare forse l'altro
siamo rimasti in pochi dovremmo scappare
altrimenti moriremo finalmente qualcuno
che l'ha capito dobbiamo trovare una via
de cesare
facciamo però proviamo qui dalla porta
vediamo io voto sì c'era una una botola
da qualche parte dove cerchio ma
cerchiamo forse se la troviamo cerchiamo
una botola forse appena di possiamo
persona 92 domanda una libreria ok
bravissimo wow bisogna salire sopra
dobbiamo trovare un qualcosa per a
princeton alto per aprirla
vediamoci cerca cercate cassis tornando
a vedere dopo avergli prima che ritorni
siamo se fosse qualcosa allora qui non
c'è nulla non stare io sto cercando
ma non
sono io quello forse al piano di sopra
se lui forse ha perso ma vorrei che sia
tardi fu del cuore niente fuori in
giardino o perché non fa più
bello bertello bravissimo per fortuna
c'è quest altro giocatore con noi
paghiamo
vediamoci luigi dall'asilo verso la
presa d'aria anche un altro labirinto
che adora vitale essere dio merda
seguimi ok e allora vai avanti
no ho sbagliato
come così
seguiamo questo questo ragazzo verde
perché forse lui sta con la via d'uscita
quindi quando si va
o no sta scadendo il tempo
non riesco a passare guardatevi spingere
quando guardo si è spostato 1 o
no
ok sono rivissuta ma vitale purtroppo è
morto e hanno fatto in tempo a leggere
comunque hanno detto che era eco vitale
povero ma vedere una trappola questa qua
infatti siamo morti tutti qui ma che
cosa devo fare adesso mi sono troppe
chiarita si sono tutti comportati bene
come direttrice sei solo tu io ti ma
c'era un mostro no quindi sarò io da
sola che dovrò affrontare la baby sitter
malefica non ci sono mostri forse stai
sognando è io rimango nascosta qua si
sta meglio e trovi vado ad adorare un
pisolino
il che vuol dire che ora si trasformerà
in mano sicuramente che continui a
parlare frutta e morto con non ci
crederà mai il mostro si 50 a tutti
dobbiamo fuggire da quasi come una
novità se propositi anche se tibor corsa
dobbiamo scappare mentre lei sta
dormendo così non lo saprò mai come
justo giocatore davvero saggio david
vediamo se non so se la porta di dietro
ancora è appena la protesi dietro questa
forse è quella del giardino emilio
perdono ragusana chiusa e bloccarla
forse il martello devi prendere di nuovo
e dov'era ha usato il ragazzo per
prendere proprio prendere questo mostro
aspetta posso aprire la porta con il
martello è morto to male fate marchio
salento il giocatore
ha rotto ei ma wow
ok scappa dall'asilo ok adesso dove devo
andare
provo ad andare di là c'è qualcosa
questo sì è un ramo magico ok ma avrei
continuato moto c'è una casa vai vai vai
a nizza stories mai
negato la questo è un altro gruppo
magico forse vuol dire che siamo secondi
sì anche perché di là ho visto una cosa
a roma e porterà meglio non andare lì
qui c'è una casetta quale finale ci
capiterà bene dico io però penso penso
che dovrò il monetario in questa foresta
dobbiamo trovare del cibo il cibo si
come facciamo a sopravvivere qua ci
dovrebbe essere qualcosa da mangiare
nella foresta di un albero
mi trovo qualcosa da mangiare alla
foresta di ml benissimo che come faccio
a prenderli a tutta quella dal
dall'albero ho trovato delle mele per da
monitorare anche se voi siete tutti
morte sera cos'è questo a devo mangiare
la mela hume
e oggi dovete contare non mi sento molto
bene
o male ma charlie mangiava mele marce no
sto morendo
ormai
non si può mangiare questo troppo non
dovevo fidarmi non dovevo mangiare
quello che abbiamo a scaldarsi perché
notte è molto freddo qua nella camera di
morire moavero bravo accendere un fuoco
oppure possiamo costruire un riparo per
me faccia ma costruirla e poi sarà data
di fare accendere fuoco forse lui salire
il fuoco ha sì ok allora accendendo il
fuoco abbiamo deciso tutti adesso e del
fuoco dividiamoci
richiamo due anni dove dovete svegliare
a4 dove erano gli altri invece non muore
eccone un'altra lettera ma con solide e
adesso ok solo uno della banca
mi ricordo che era qui vicino però
riccione 14 di fronte ok ok ho acceso il
fornello è una musica inquietante se
arriva un orso
stanno in alto il temporale bambino
anche allora sono morta moon poter
rispondere che se rimani qui che forse è
meglio se la tempesta mia uccisa così
ora sono qua nella caverna ma tengo se
quella della rossa
passeremo al riparo si
sopravvissuti stiamo al nostro previti
temporale è finito o no sono tutto solo
adesso ma non è vero
bari sono tour in realtà aspettando
cos'è quella luce ebbe in fondo quale
luce non lo so che cosa ho visto
forse devi salire su per vederla meglio
a casa si potrebbe entrare questa casa
sembra carina la porta è aperta quasi
che cosa è questo
forse è meglio non entrare al mare forse
un fantasma che ha visto avvista un
altro fantasma non so se devo entrare
uno forse non rientrare vediamo
ma cos'è questo tipo il teletrasporto
ma sei sicura sembra una sorta di tre
tra noi chiudiamo
queste rocce hanno bloccato la porta
sono era una trappola giorno blumone
rate
in parlamento si sta aprendo
salta su quell'asse
dove sono finiti dalle viscere del
terreno deve saltare non puoi saltare no
aspetta aspetta qua aspetta forse adesso
uscirà fuori così da avere una tenacia
il prima possibile o che fazioni e si fa
sempre più intrigante interessante
andare mai in alto ok devi saltare
immagino ha cambiato il tempo
sta scadendo vai piano ma corri
ok sono stati cinque secondi quanto
saputo esprimere si deve esprimere
siamo sopravvissuti che succede che cosa
ma sei tu sfracellato di una
quarta quello basato il demone abbiamo
trovato la sua base come faccio a
attraversare una spada bellissima potrò
prenderla un po forse riuscirà a
sconfiggere il demone riuscirò pager vai
o no vediamo il ponte
stai attento potrebbe essere una
trappola prova ad avvicinarti e vedere
se puoi prendere quella spada
non mi fa avvicinare
quesito mi to ear e
[Musica]
allora devo affrontare
sì ci incontriamo ancora il mostro dico
io
sono io cosa state facendo nella mia
base
io
mi sono sfracellato
basta mi sono stancato di sentire le
vostre voci fastidiose abbiamo gestito
sai che cosa succede a noi cosa sia
successo nella mia rizzi si miei
sfracellati beh succederà anche a voi
adesso tutte store motivo
devo prendere la spada non avrei st
uscito prima ok presa spa la
cucina si mostrano maggio come se già
non ci credo
al vostro passaggio a nanto niente la
tua mano
ma l'inizio è stato facile sembra che
sia stato troppo facile c'è qualcosa di
strano ora è lì si scommette domenicali
non vediamo se secondo persone non sta
rivivendo
[Applauso]
e sparito abbiamo fitto non ci credo
buona nel mezzo secret ending e ho vinto
vittori
ma cosa più bella che era secret quindi
non non succede spesso mi sarà infatti
la si possa credere più nuovo testicolo
tending anche se non non sappiamo se
alla fine era lì lì o no il debole
perché l'abbiamo c'e dalle tavole
lasciate un bel grigio nelle altre
stanze ora mi lasciavo quattro
casalinghe su cui cliccare per vedere
gli altri video cliccate su qualche
preferite buona visione ciao